Hey what's up guys, did you know you can make your own butter? A couple of years ago
I put out a tutorial showing how you can take heavy whipping cream from the store put it in a glass
Mason jar and shake it vigorously for about 10 minutes and the whole thing would start solidifying and turning into a clump of butter.
It's an awesome experiment that really does work a lot of you tried it. the problem
is that it takes 10 minutes of vigorous shaking now everyone
I know who's tried turning cream into butter, takes it straight out of the fridge, puts it in a container and start shaking it
until it eventually turns into butter this takes a monumental effort.
So for this video I want to give you an update on a little technique
I discovered that can shrink that 10 minutes of effort down to around 20 seconds.
You might be surprised to know, that all it takes to do this in 20 seconds is
First, set your container of cream on the counter and let it warm up to room temperature first.
Now the kind of cream you want to get is called heavy whipping cream
and you'll find this stuff over by the milk section in your local grocery store
So I've just let this cream warm up to about 78 79 degrees Fahrenheit
That's room temperature, and that's gonna work really well.
So now all you need to make this work is some kind of container like a water bottle with a screw-off lid
because once our butter is made. we're gonna need a way to get this back out, so widemouth is gonna work the best
I'm just showing you guys this is cream. That was just freshly poured out of the container you can see it's liquidy
I have not shaken this at all. So we're gonna put this lid on and in that condition once it's screwed on tight
I'm going to hold my finger down and we're going to shake this as hard as we can
For about 20 seconds and see if we can't turn the butter let's begin!
There we go, few seconds in it. It's already turned to whipping cream now
We need to do is push a little harder and get that cream to break as soon as it breaks. We're back into bottle.
Got a whip what the good there goes alright guys it just broke come here check this out
Alright, so it went from a liquid state, then it went into a cream state and now it's gone back to it's liquid state
I'm just shaking a little bit more so all the globules of butter can collect together, a little bit of a workout
But I didn't break a sweat now
let's open this up and lets see what  we got inside!
Little bit of heavy breathing, but that didn't hurt anybody check it out guys nice glob of butter
See see right now our butter kind of looks like we gotta cheese, and that's because there's a lot of buttermilk in there
We can go ahead and pour off that buttermilk using and cooking drink it
good stuff alright
I'm just going to put the cap back on shake this a few more times
This will help blob the butter back together into a nice ball for us
If I transfer this to a container for you
There we go look at that beautiful chunk of butter made from whipping cream. How amazing is that?
Looks like butter smells like butter
Definitely tastes like a butter. We know this could use a little salt just
need a pinch
You might even be a little it too much. They're just going to work that in
By adding a little bit of salt to your butter
It's going to make it taste delicious
And it's going to act as a natural preservative so this stuff should be able to last for a week or two
Especially be stored in the fridge my theory on why this works is because the molecules of cream
I think are similar to water balloons
Imagine for a second you have a bucket of water balloons each of those balloons has a thick rubbery coating
but if you slosh that bucket hard enough
You could eventually get those balloons to collide and those rubber skins to break that's a sense that we're doing with the cream here
We're shaking it so hard that we're getting the membranes to break and release the butter molecules in the solution so cream that comes
Right out of the fridge is like cold water balloon that's going to be a lot harder to get those to pop
That's why I letting your cream sit out for a couple of hours can make the difference between working for 10 minutes and working for
A matter of seconds now the way, we store butter at our house is by using something called the butter crock
This is a two-piece unit that has water in one side and a cupped bowl shape in the other you fill the bowl up with
Butter and then you turn upside down and push it down into the water this creates an airtight seal that will prevent any
Bacteria from getting in there and causing your butter to go bad now
I'm not going to lie and say that making this was easy
But it definitely is a lot easier
Than making it with cream that comes straight out of the fridge so go try for yourself head down to the grocery store pick up
Some whipping cream let it warm up to room temperature and put it in the bottle and shake it
So you got yourself some butter add a pinch of salt spread on a cracker. You got yourself a snack
hey, thanks for joining me for this experiment today has been awesome hanging out with you
And I'll be there for you in the next video. Talk to you there!
Its Stuck to the edges